random thought  we get on all these exercise regimens  health and wellness what about like a  kind regimen what about if every [ __ ]  person this upcoming week just decided  when they were like feeling angry or  mean at someone that they just [ __ ]  decided to flip it and be gracious and  empathetic and compassionate to that  person and be the bigger person and just  show a little love how about this week's  regimen is it  isn't it  protein or calories and all that [ __ ]  what about it's an emotional kind work  that every time you're triggered and  you're ready to [ __ ] bark at someone  you just take a big [ __ ] mental step  back and decide to deploy love instead  of letting your insecurity Professor  hate  just a [ __ ] thought